how exactly do you teach a robot
traditionally to get a robot to do what
you want requires programming a list of
tasks or rules to follow which often
means nuance and the unpredictable are
left out or than many AI systems the
robot learns from massive sets of
training data what if you could make a
robot figure it out for itself based on
concepts and inference researchers have
developed a new system for teaching
robots concepts by presenting them a
pair of images and having them figure
out how to transform one to the other in
real life the goal is to introduce a
method of learning used by humans all
the time learning by inference like
looking at the instructions for
assembling an IKEA chair let's take an
easier example you use two images of
apples the input on the left and the
output on the right for us it's easy to
see how the apples are reorganized by
position and color the trick here is to
make a robot recognize the conceptual
differences plan the changes needed and
then act on that plan researchers
experimented with two different robots
each equipped with a camera at the end
of a gripper for manipulating different
objects on a tabletop they presented the
robots with a pair of images an input
and an output representing your concept
each concept consisted of different
shapes colors and positions which are
captured by the camera and then run
through special software
it was then up to the robots to infer
exactly how to rearrange the objects on
the tabletop to match the output image
in each concept
the robots achieved that by evaluating
the different matchups in their
imagination to arrive at a program that
described the concept researchers used a
dataset of five hundred and forty six
different concepts to test the robots
and the robots successfully learned five
hundred and thirty five of them
researchers then tested six of these
concepts with real-world variations in
objects backgrounds and complexities
despite those variations the robots were
able to successfully execute the
concepts they even found that they could
teach the robots the steps needed by
directing their attention with a pointer
researchers believe that in the future
systems like these could be used to help
robots achieve tasks without copying the
movements of people in new situations
never encountered before
[Music]